right now the market crashed right i
think the market's going to crash pretty
bad the next six 12 24 months i think
it's gonna be very ugly
and i agree a lot of people are gonna
get hurt in a very big way but you know
what i think is gonna happen in five to
ten years market's gonna go down's gonna
hit 60 000 in the next 10 15 years okay
what do you think is going to happen in
the next five years we're going to have
a trillionaire what do we think is going
to happen in the next 20 years we're
going to have 10 trillionaires i mean
that's going to keep happening right and
in the market in the climate change
stuff oh but look what's going on today
i don't care what's going on today i
want to see the difference of what's
happened last 50 years
oh what's going on this year look what
happened to the temperatures give me 100
years which i kind of you know go back
to your argument
what i'm asking right now is
if we double two more times we've got 32
billion people here
we can't have 32 billion people in this
in the world